most Americans like their odds of making
more money in the new year 76 percent in
a new fidelity investment study believe
they'll be better off financially in
2018 than they were last year but only
27% plan to make a financial resolution
for this year and that is an all-time
low in this survey CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger has some ideas
to help you improve and simplify your
financial life good morning to you Jill
good morning and Happy New Year happy
new year so the study shows that most
people are worried about unexpected
unexpected expenses number one what does
that mean what are you talking about
there and so what can we do to safeguard
against that to get ready for that well
you know unexpected we always say like
what's your emergency reserve fund so
that can be anything from oh my gosh I
got in a little yeah leaky roof the the
washer dryer just exploded something bad
happens and it could also be a car
repair we know that actually a lot of
parents help their adult children out
with car repairs so one of the things
that I've always talked about especially
after the holiday season in terms of
what you should be doing is you should
be focused on what we call the big three
did you incur some credit card debt over
the holidays number one let's make a
plan to pay that down number two did you
drain some money out of that emergency
reserve fund I know you hate when I tell
you this but six months of your living
expenses should be kept safe that was
next question how much are you supposed
to happen that emergency where you're
saying six months of your expense people
can't do that I know but you know what
we've got to strive for something right
and the other part is that once those
two things are done please try to
maximize your retirement plan
contributions as much as you can
here in 2018 new 401 K limit $18,500 six
thousand dollars more if you're over the
age of fifty fifty five hundred in your
IRA or your Roth IRA sixty five hundred
if you're over the age of fifty when
it's been a very good year for stocks
what about our investments well I think
that when you come off of a huge year
like we've just had and somewhat
unexpectedly I don't think many people a
year ago thought we would have this
strong a year is a perfect time to say
let me look at what I have let me look
at the stuff that's in my retirement
and should I rebalance it that means
that if you're the kind of investor who
doesn't love risk you're a balanced
investor maybe you started 2017 saying
50% stocks and 50% funds well the
markets were so good this year you might
be 70% in stocks right now so you want
to take some of the money out of the
stocks move it into the bonds and
rebalance those allocations the other
part that's really important many people
are in these big plans they get company
stock as part of their 401k rebalance
that as well because you've had a great
year mostly you don't want to take extra
risk unnecessarily and the people that
don't have stocks and they're saying
look I just overspent this holiday
season getting back on track you
recommend well I think I think the most
important thing is to have an expense
tracker so there's really good ones
mint.com you need a budget or something
from your bank keep track of how you're
spending your money be sure to go to
your annual credit report.com once a
year check those credit reports
make sure you correct any any errors and
be clear guard those that identity like
it's like I got a ADA breach that way
you got it is there something called you
need a budget or you need a budget why
any but you need a budget yeah you don't
need a budget bill thank you so much
sure all the best everybody in 2018
exponentially she said you don't know
what Arnie's that's true
[Laughter]